hi my name is michael robinson i'm a
research associate at the institute for
sustainable food systems at kpu
i'm here today to share a little bit
about our hog research project
specifically to take you through the
process of moving the hogs into a new
rotational grazing plot
so as you can see here we begin by
unhooking the fence from the back edge
of the previous grazing plot
and moving it up into its new position
this allows the hogs to move into their
new plot
they're pretty well trained by this
point and with little hesitation they
move into their stand to
field b's notes
feed
well not always necessary we like to
ensure the hogs stay in their new plot
with a little extra feed
next we move their shelter into the plot
these are a mobile shelter designed to
be moved by one or two people
and to comfortably house both hogs in
each plot
well the hogs are distracted with the
food we move the back fence up
and close them fully into the new plot
the last thing that needs done is moving
and setting back up the barrel water
system we use for these hogs
this move took us all of three minutes
we think that rotational grazing systems
like this
really represent a great option for
raising hog on pasture
it's low labor and the materials needed
are quite affordable
all right finally we wanted to say
thanks for watching
we hope something in the system people
find useful
stay tuned for more videos demonstrating
some of our infrastructure
day before move prep and more
you